this planetary nebulas simple graceful  appearance is due to perspective our  view from planet Earth looking at just  the right angle to see a cosmic ring  made from a cloud of gas shrugged off by  a dying star this planetary nebula is  not the same as a supernova remnant  supernovas only happen for high mass  stars this is the result of a low mass  star ejecting its outer layer and  becoming a white dwarf which you can  still see at the center of the image the  colors in this image indicate the  temperature of the stellar gas shroud  hot blue gas near the energizing central  star gives way to progressively cooler  green and yellow gas at greater  distances with the coolest red gas along  the outer boundary